hi everyone welcome to the daily
homeroom livestream for those of you all
who are wondering what this is when we
started having physical school closures
we realized and everyone had to be
socially distance we we realized that
it's our duty really as a not-for-profit
with a mission of free world-class
education for anyone anywhere to not
only accelerate the development of a lot
of the software tools and the content
but also try to create as many supports
as possible for parents teachers and
students as we go through this a fairly
tough time and we've been running
webinars for teachers and parents to
understand how to use the different kind
of County resources and we've been doing
other things but we thought it'd be fun
to have a way to connect and taste
synchronous and have conversations
during this time of social distancing so
welcome to this live stream I do like to
make my standard announcement Khan
Academy is a not-for-profit we only can
exist because of philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself I want to give
a special shout out to several
corporations that have stepped up in the
last few weeks to help us especially
with the covin response we were running
at a deficit even before the crisis and
our costs have gone up we're seeing
about 2.5 3x the traffic we normally do
or trying to accelerate a bunch of
programs so special thanks to Google to
Bank of America Google org AT&T fast the
end of artists and to the many other
philanthropic and corporate supporters
pre-crisis as well who continue to
support us and special thanks to the
many thousands of people who donate
whatever they can you know $3 $5 it all
makes a difference and it all adds up
because it allows us to serve many many
many millions of students so today we've
been having some incredible guests and
I'm sorry to announce that today's guest
is not so impressive it's me so every
now and then we like to mix in having
guests and just you know a time for you
to ask me anything you would like to ask
me and I say that in the broadest
possible terms I have yet to be offended
by a question although I don't want to
encourage you too much but please on
YouTube and Facebook ask me anything and
we have team members who are looking at
the message boards on both YouTube and
Facebook to surface any questions and so
already there's one from Facebook Kesava
Rahman asks hi Sal please
answer my questions well I am answering
it right now how did you study and how
did you recommend studying please give a
comparison on effectiveness well I'll
tell you what has worked that worked for
me growing up and even today you know a
lot of people ask me Sal how do you
cover you know how do you make a lesson
on organic chemistry and a lesson on the
Napoleonic Wars and a lesson on physics
and some of those subjects I have a deep
intuition and I know from my academic
background but a lot of them I have to
study to learn it well and so whether it
was when I was in school or even now
when I'm studying I have a very active
process when I'm doing one I like if I'm
doing something especially in math or
the sciences I like to work through
problems and sometimes it's problems I
can find in a textbook or on say Khan
Academy and sometimes it's problems I'm
coming up with myself I was like well
exactly how does a lead to be so my
number one thing is while you are
studying constantly ask yourself
questions and even in a subject matter
like history where you say okay I have
to read this fairly dense chapter of my
history textbook to understand or to get
a sense of the context of things
constantly asking yourself questions
like why what why did Julius Caesar
cross the Rubicon I mean they're up did
he really think he could do it and and
what that does is one it forces
connections where it frankly just makes
everything more interesting but you're
also going to retain a lot more because
you're hot you're engaging more of your
brain on that concept so it's not just
about memorizing Julius Caesar across
the Rubicon in such-and-such a date but
when you start to put yourself in his
shoes and say okay what's the risk
reward you know he here would you what I
have done the same thing in that
situation or if you're in biology class
well why does that make sense or just
even experiencing the aww of it you know
when you study the cell and you're Eli
says just it's almost like a whole
civilization in there had so much
complexity and there's some you know it
puts you in awe of how hollow everything
all works together and I think when you
study with that type of a mindset not
only is this studying more in fact more
effective but it is more more enjoyable
I would say one key though is to not do
it in a stressed State and to do that
it's all about building a habit so that
you're able to learn
consistently and do you know depending
on your age level or what you're
studying 20 30 40 minutes every day try
to make it as active as possible and
then what you see is by the time you get
to a test it'll feel intuitive versus if
you cram it you know six hours you know
six hours the night before the exam and
even if you're studying on Khan Academy
if you're watching a video always try to
pause the video try to do it yourself
whether it's me or someone else making
the video before we work through it try
to see whether you could even come up
with some of the intuitions about it
before we explain it and even if you do
you know you watch the whole video then
stop it say okay let me see if I can
replicate the thought process let me see
if I can explain it now let me see if I
can go through that same worked example
so the more active you make it the
better see other questions from Immanuel
Peter asks from YouTube are you going to
put a geography course on Khan Academy
we don't unfortunately have near-term
plans to do a geography course emmanuel
I would love to eventually you know the
vision of Khan Academy is all of the
course subjects we have Khan Academy
kids now so really from pre-k through
elementary middle school high school and
even the core college but we do not have
geography yet which i think is a is a
very valuable course so hopefully one
day some of it is resources for you know
any philanthropists or corporate
sponsors out there or individual donors
you know things like middle school
science geography middle school science
is actually one of the areas that we
would really like to find some supports
for if we can we're starting to do stuff
in English and language arts for grades
2 through 8 but that's another area
where we would love to talk to potential
sponsors and you know the Khan Academy
kids effort there was just this efficacy
study that came out it was a randomized
control trial which means they randomly
put students into one of two groups the
control group or the or the the
treatment group and in the treatment
group the control group they used a kind
of a family-friendly app these are
four-year-olds four-year-olds who come
from high poverty families and then the
treatment group they use Khan Academy
kids 20 minutes a day and the treatment
group after I think it was about a month
and a half they were completely they
were able to close the gap between some
of these really high need communities
these high need students and their more
affluent peers so these students went
from roughly the 30th percentile to the
percent tell in the week and a half so
that's another area that I would love to
add more if we can find the resources it
goes up to first grade I would love to
add to second grade third grade and then
you know internationalize but no no
geography just yet okay from Facebook
Ozma a bow asks hi I'm new to using Khan
Academy kids Apple we were just talking
about that or Khan Academy app do you
have both in both apps in Arabic I did a
quick search and I found you have a
website in Arabic but I actually
couldn't find it any clarification as
much as appreciated so thanks for asking
Ozma so unfortunately we do not have
either app in Arabic yet we do have many
localization projects around the world
you can imagine though languages like
Arabic and and Farsi and Hebrew and or
though they are right-to-left and
sometimes bi-directional languages and
we haven't been able to build that into
our product yet that is one of our two
do's that we hope to be able to do one
day with that said there is a
translation project of Khan Academy into
Arabic and I think if you do Google
search you should be able to find that
translation project so it's not the full
functionality it's not the exercises and
and all of that but at least the videos
there are versions that have been either
dubbed or redone in Arabic so you know
definitely take try to see if you can
find find those resources
Elliot H from YouTube says did you have
any earlier startups that failed simple
answer is yes I have had my share a
years you know I don't even remember
them all I'm someone that probably I've
always had a few Harebrained Schemes as
early as I remember I remember in
college I was trying to start actually
we won some business plan competitions I
was trying to start a effort looks at my
internet connection is doing weird
things right now I'm I hope y'all can
hear me but in college I started an
effort that it was actually around
education where if you have an EEG which
can measure kind of mental activity
you know can mention the various cycles
of brainwaves that if if you if students
were able to stay focused on something
say doing math problems it would reward
them and that if they lose their focus
while doing it it would say hey come
back you know snap snap yeah come look
at what you know stay focus on the
problem so if we'd called it cerebral
technologies but we never got too far
with that then you know during my first
job on the side I was trying to you know
I had this idea this was in the early
this was in the late 90s I had this idea
of locally scoped domain names this was
yet you know there's obviously domain
names there for the whole world but like
what about pizza calm which shouldn't
that go to your local pizza parlor not
just to some random global pizza place
so that was the idea that you could get
these domain names would they go to
different places depending on where you
are we got a little further but that
didn't go in too far and then and then I
joined a start-up in the late 90s called
me VC and this was a legitimate startup
it had venture funding and all the rest
and I was there kind of their CTO and it
got pretty far we grew to 40 people we
actually the whole idea was to
democratize venture capital and that you
know the reason why they even needed a
CTO is that we were building a platform
so that anyone who invested even a
dollar into the venture capitalists
funds could in the venture capital funds
could see what you know understand the
entrepreneurs understand the businesses
that they were investing in things like
that but then the the Nasdaq collapsed
was it in fall in spring of 2000 and
that's when I said maybe I should go to
business school and then even you know
and and actually even even and even
before business school me and a buddy
just tried to we started this thing
called truth bites which did hindsight
we probably should have kept at it in
you know it was priests the big social
media wave but it was essentially you
sign up all your friends and you could
ask questions that you normally you know
feel less comfortable being open about
and you could answer them with some
level of anonymity and it was kind of a
way to foster more open and vulnerable
communication between food and folks so
that that's just some of my list of
startups failed startups and actually
there's more there's actually you know I
joined a hedge fund out of business
school and it was called wool capital
was just me and my boss Dan and we ended
up hiring a few more analysts and it was
it did very well but then Dan decided to
retire and he encouraged me to start my
own fund and so I literally you know
took over his expenses and his team his
office which was very expensive was
costing a lot of money and I started
something called Kahn Capital Management
and that was a month before fall of 2008
were into the entire stock market
collapse and I still am a little
defensive about it because Kahn Capital
did exist it existed for about eight
months and even in that year we were up
four percent in a year that the market
was down 40 percent so that's my slide
insecurity trying to justify it failed
despite performance but it obviously
wasn't an environment where people were
interested in investing in a new and a
new investment fund and so you know that
actually was a that was a tough one
because that actually I I we burned a
lot of our savings frankly on that so
that was that was actually one of the
harder ones I can laugh about it in
hindsight and then and then Khan Academy
so yes
I think I think that's actually a pretty
comprehensive list but a good question
so Maya Sharma from YouTube says we are
we in a recession and what stocks should
we invest in so the first part is easy
to answer I think the simple answer is
yes you know a recession there's
multiple you know strict definitions of
it but it's usually two quarters of kind
of reduced economic growth obviously
because of the quarantines and then even
once where are those stay in place
orders and then even once we're out of
it people's behavior is going to change
they're going to travel less they're
going to go to restaurants less well
even the restaurants that are open
they're gonna have to have less capacity
because they're gonna have to be
socially distanced so you're definitely
any of you just look at the unemployment
number it's not just in the US and
around the world and so it's very clear
we're for sure in a recession already
and and unfortunately the question is
how bad will it be you know I'm not in
I'm not in in in the investment world
anymore we've had some interesting folks
like Ray Dalio and Mellody Hobson who
are you know some of the top investors
in the world on on this live stream and
you know from what I hear from them
there's there's definitely you know
sometimes with the stock market is
incredibly volatile right now that's
very hard to time when you get in but
you know when there is a lot of
volatility and a lot of emotions in the
market that is a time that interesting
opportunities can sometimes get lost in
the fray so I would say if you are
diligent and you look for things and you
look for things that have a good thesis
and a thesis that can do well and any
type of economy you you might find some
some diamonds in the rough so to speak
but you know III do say that I I know
how sophisticated many investors are and
I know all of the work that we used to
do when we were when I was an analyst at
a hedge fund and so I'm actually afraid
to be a stock picker today because I
know that there's a version of myself on
the other side of that trade who's doing
a lot more analysis than I can then I
have the time to do right now so most of
most you know I do it before o 1k then I
that's passively you know it's just an
index things but most of you know my
savings I use it to pay down our
mortgage and to you know we do have like
a rental property and I don't know and I
have no idea how that's all going to
play out with with with with what's
going on it's it's going to be a tough
you know my best British is gonna be a
tough couple of years coming up so yeah
I definitely would shy away from doing
anything very risky but this is not a
place for me to give you too much
investment advice take it all with the
grain of salt
so this Zarya con from youtube not a
question just to comment says i remember
seeing him younger than this so yes I
guess I've aged thank you for pointing
that out in fairness you know it many
years of you might remember Khan Academy
Sal Khan from 2008-2009 that's when we
first started really getting on people's
radars and it's been 11 years since and
so you know I try to wear the cream and
the lotion and sunscreen and but you
know we all age and the beard I heard
you know cuz it's gray it has gray in it
so whatever
it's a it's a trade-off these are good
questions and comments from YouTube
Michelle Mitchell says hi Sal how did
you pick a major in college
good question Michelle so for me well
I'll tell you what my thinking was when
I was maybe your age if you are picking
that major right now I was I guess you
could say I'm a romantic in that when I
was in high school I was convinced you
know I was obsessed with physics I said
I want to be a theoretical physics a PhD
one day I want to ponder the nature of
reality I want to answer the big
questions and then and even in my
college applications when they said what
you know what do you want a major and I
said physics theoretical physics and
when I got to college it was actually
around that same summer before college
there was a local professor that found
out that I had a lot of interest in math
and computing and also found out that I
didn't have a computer and so he had
access to computer so he gave me a
summer internship and so I was able to
essentially learn to code using you know
a proper computer actually quite good
computers you know these kind of mini
computers that are one step up above PC
type you know back then in the mid 90s
and that's where I started getting a
real love for computing and I said well
you know there's something about about
programming where you can create
realities you know and people even
debate whether the reality we live in is
a simulation but that kind of got me
excited about hey could you create
realities could you create experiences
and there was also something about
technology and programming that I liked
is that it could scale you know if you
create an interesting experience and
theory an unlimited number of people
could use it and that was pretty
compelling and so I event I decided to
become a computer science major and math
major at the same time and that's the
path I went down and you know as I got
further in my undergrad I started
thinking about well what about money and
you know I didn't come from a wealthy
family my mother made I think 16
thousand dollars in 1993 and the only
reason why I remember that is I had to
do her taxes so that I could get her
laid I remember the number very clearly
and and and
you know I was I was you know MIT was
very generous with the financial aid but
I still was incurring about give or take
about ten thousand dollars a year in
debt and you know that was a lot of
money for my family and so I near the
end of my undergrad I started thinking
very seriously about how do I pay this
back how do I start making money how do
I help out my family and I was going to
do a master's but I kind of hurried that
up by taking a few more classes and then
and then the good thing is with the late
90s and I you know I hadn't really
thought about it much but kind of CS was
a very it was a very in demand career as
it as it continues to be so it worked
out financially well actually I'll take
that back it's not like I didn't think
about it at all
I think you know when you when you come
from fairly humble circumstances I don't
think you oftentimes even allow yourself
to go into a field that might be viewed
as a little less than practical so I
think that was definitely one of the
constraints for me you know if if I were
giving advice to you or to a family
member who's 17 18 years old 19 years
old and thinking about their major I
would say fine fine you know especially
in the economy that we're about to go
and look at the fields that you know
there's demand for you know I I know
this sounds like very pragmatic advice
because it is but if if you're able to
if you're able to kind of put you know
money on the table food on the table but
however you want to describe it and you
feel productive that was going to open
up a lot more things to you in your life
and so you know it doesn't you know
everyone talks about computing now and
obviously if that's something you're
excited about definitely go into it but
there's a lot of other interesting areas
you know I I growing up I thought
something like accounting is kind of you
know that's bean-counting etc etc but
then when I went to business school I
discovered that Finance and Accounting
are fascinating subjects and that's why
actually why I had this career
transition into investing so I think
there's a lot of things that we very
easily can get programmed by stereotypes
we might have a friend or a family mr.
don't go into that that's you know those
people are like this or like that or
that career is boring but give it a shot
and almost any field if you put yourself
in the right mindset actually can be
fascinating so that's that's the
vici I could give but you know
definitely try to come out of college
with some skills that you think have a
good chance of you know you're gonna be
able to pay off your debt and things
like that I do have people in my family
and it's a it's a and this is you know
just a microcosm for the whole country
I don't think colleges talk to freshmen
enough about the implications of the
debt and that how it can stay with you a
very long time and I don't think they
give enough data to freshmen and
sophomores who are picking their majors
to tell them okay people who majored in
X what are their job prospects like when
they graduate how much are they making
what percentage of them have paid off
their debt what percentage of them out
are in default over their debt ten years
out fifteen years out and I know these
are kind of buzzkill
answers but I think it's super important
so you know if you can try to do some of
that research yourself talk to people go
to your college and say you know try to
find alums who are you know in the major
you're interested in they're one year
out five year out ten year out ten years
out and I think they'll be very frank
with you some of them will say it was
the best decision I ever made to major
in X and some will say um you know it's
not as easy as I thought to make a
living in this X or maybe I am making a
living but you know the subject matter
is one thing but then the job is a
different thing so that's that's the
best advice I could give I will give a
plug you know a bank for America has
been a longtime sponsor of work we've
been doing in financial literacy and in
careers and so look up Khan Academy
careers and better money habits at Bank
of America and you'll actually see a
bunch of video profiles of people in
different careers and and understanding
the trade-offs in them
okay so IBG --the poq are says what
inspires you to learn various topics
well for me I you know we're in this
mystery called life and you know I've
said it before on this live stream we
you know there's been thousands of years
of accumulated human knowledge and most
of the things that are you know now a
paragraph in your textbook or video on
Khan Academy that's oftentimes the
culmination of many people's lifetime
work and they would do anything they
would have had done anything to have
access to that information and so I
always remind myself there's something
interesting about this that someone
wanted to devote
their life - and there usually is you
know I mean the sigh and subject I mean
they're there you know when you look at
literature and how it you know how it
can evoke human emotions and and and
trans and transport you to another time
or another even perspective you know
that's somewhat magical if you look at
the sciences they really are all about
understanding the nature of our reality
the nature of life the nature of how all
you know how you know a just a handful
of elements can you know combined in
different ways to form a sal or an avi
jeath these are mind-blowing
mind-blowing things so that that's what
gets me excited and obviously i have an
extra motivation that if i can really
digest it and stay excited about it then
i can hopefully be a little bit
infectious with that and and help other
people get excited about it as well so
there from Joanna Mena from Facebook Sal
do you have suggestions how to keep kids
engaged in online school sometimes they
study to have good grades for the
teachers but while studying from home
they don't have the engagement with
other humans and lose interest
you're asking a super important question
Joanne you know and I won't pretend like
I've solved it all all of it at home my
older children you know we might they go
to school that I helped start called
Khan lab school and they've done a
really good job of essentially helping
young people you know my kids are 11
eight and five and especially the 11 and
eight-year-old who've been in kind of
the system where there's been a lot of
emphasis on agency students set their
goals but then once a week they check in
with their teachers to review their
goals so there is accountability around
it but that muscle that they've been
built building over many years even
priek ovid it's it seems to be serving
them well right now and their teachers
are doing an incredible job kind of
keeping it going over the over the
course of this the situation we're in
so I I do see even young kids as young
as seven eight nine years old if they're
used to that muscle of okay you you have
a set number of goals for the day for
the week for the term and that there's a
daily and then maybe weekly or maybe
quarterly
term check-in that actually can be
pretty good and then you know on the
day-to-day I think it's all about
structure it's all about habit you know
our five-year-old has been maybe the
most difficult but even with him the
more we get the structure and the habit
and we celebrate the small wins and we
make sure there's a lot of time for
breaks and we don't try to do too much
at once you know we say hey you know for
the five-year-old if we can get a
productive hour and a half today that's
a win and then once we get into the
habit of that productive hour-and-a-half
we're going to keep going but then for
my older kids it's all about you know
just making sure they have balance even
in this these times of social distancing
that they have time to go outside
that they they have time to play they
have time to do creative things that
while they're doing their independent
work or their their Xoom sessions with
their teachers that they that they're
taking breaks they're stretching and
things like that that's the best I can
give there's other resources we've had
parents into teacher webinars that go
into much more depth on this and
obviously we've released things like
daily schedules and and learning plans
to help with some of this but I think
those check-ins with both parents and
and teachers that hold their students a
little bit accountable and they know
they're gonna come that helps them build
that muscle so I would just say stick to
it
it can sometimes be a little messy at
first but over time if there's a silver
lining is that students could build more
of that agency in that independence
muscle so let's see from from off table
con from Facebook any plans in India we
actually have a whole team in India kind
of CAD me India team there's several
folks in in Delhi and in Bangalore
so yes simple answers we have plans I
could go over the whole in the effort
but if you do some web searches on it
you should be able to find our India you
know we have an English version of Khan
Academy which is for those of you don't
know English it's a hybrid between Hindi
and English we're translating into on
redoing actually and many of the
languages in India were mapping to many
of the state standards so India is
actually one of our geographies that
were very focused on the other is Brazil
spanish-speaking Latin America and then
as as I mentioned there's 45 translation
projects from mainly volunteers around
around the world
so Adam Boop cur reacts is it possible
to take the SCT from Khan Academy you
could prepare for the SAT from Khan
Academy but the the administration is
not on Khan Academy but I highly
recommend you know even if you're not
taking the SATs right now the when we've
partnered with the College Board on this
we said we don't want this just to be
superficial test prep we want this to be
something that really helps students
become more college ready improves their
mathematical critical thinking their
reading comprehension their writing
skills so actually our SAT practice the
official ICT practice on Khan Academy I
actually think it's a great thing for
anyone for sure any high school students
and even maybe some middle school
students to start doing putting in half
an hour a day forty minutes a day if you
do that I think you're gonna find that
you're going to really build those
muscles especially through this kind of
kovat crisis and through the summer and
then when you happen to take the SAT
here's gonna be like oh this just all
makes sense this is all pretty
straightforward and frankly you'll just
be that much more college ready
so from YouTube Explorer questioner
unorthodox question for Sal do you
perhaps garden not a little bit my wife
is the gardener and she would like me to
be more of a gardener and you know so
I'm trying to garden more my wife does a
wonderful job we have a very pleasant
garden maybe one day I'll do our live
stream from from our from our backyard
but but I I definitely see the appeal
but I just haven't you know if I if I
claim to do any gardening if my wife is
watching she would roll her eyes so I
will I won't make claims that I can't
back up from YouTube Anglo Indian boy do
you play chess I do but I play at a I
would say a I'm a very good amateur and
my 11 year old son is getting is we're
about even now so he's he's he's on the
site chess kids which I have to you know
give credit it's you know he spends time
on that every if whenever I win he goes
and like he goes and like learns new
things new openings and used
and then he comes back and then he
usually beats me so I'm he's he's undef
initely a much faster trajectory and I
think we're about a year way where you
know he might III might not be able to
beat him anymore but yeah I would
consider myself a good amateur chess
player but I definitely definitely love
the game let's see well I do say I mean
I will brag a little bit there was this
this there was at this event in Silicon
Valley Magnus Carlsen was there a chess
champion for those of you don't know of
the world and he offered to play for
people blindfolded and my name was
picked from the Hat of the people there
so I was one of the four people who got
to play Magnus Carlsen he was
blindfolded and playing four of us at
the same time but I was the last person
standing so there was a he took care of
the other three and then he's obviously
blindfolded and then and there was a
moment in the game where I actually had
an advantage but then when his entire
chess brain power was focused on me I
could almost like feel it and it was
incredibly intimidating and then I just
panicked and he won not to say that he
wouldn't of what if I didn't panic
famous favorite board game where all the
time but I can go a little bit longer I
think I have a time you know what's your
favorite board game from Alexander theis
kovitch sorry if I'm mispronouncing your
name Alexander from Facebook I'm a big
fan of risk monopoly and Settlers of
Catan but with all of them they get much
better if you add kind of a notion of
markets to them so I have a version of
risk that I play it's kind of a paranoia
risk where paranoia risk is where every
every army is their goal is to try to
remove another army from the board but
you don't know who's trying to remove
you and so you could imagine there's a
lot of intrigue and and what you do is
you can create stocks for each color and
then you can have a another separate
group of twenty to thirty people trading
securities so if that color wins it's
worth a hundred at the end of the game
if they lose those words
and so at any given point in time the
value of that color trading should be
the probability that they win the game
that's a fun thing and monopoly I like
to add notions of investors so there's
even people who are you know they're
willing to take equity stakes in in
various players you can introduce things
like insurance contracts debt
instruments on in monopoly so I think
that's pretty you know corporate
structures so that you can have multiple
investors in like the shoe so that's a
fun way to and in settlers of catan you
can actually you know there's something
I used to do in summer camps I used to
run with middle school students you can
play Settlers of Catan with no trading
you could play trading at your board
then you can play trading where you have
other boards and then you could trade
you can kind of do that as international
trade and then you could you could
introduce some form of currency and then
what's interesting is you can see it on
every one of those steps more trade will
create more building and more currency
will create more building just because
there's you know more people are able to
get what they need so it's a good way of
understanding money and the value of
trade so so other questions here and I
know we're all at I'll answer one or two
more so josy mubarak from youtube says
given the kovat 19 has given the effect
its had on primary and secondary schools
what has been the effect on the khan
academy platform
well jody Zozi we've seen our traffic be
about depending on the day two hundred
fifty percent to three hundred percent
of normal traffic so we've definitely
seen a huge increase in load on the
platform i guess that's the main effect
you know the effect on the organization
obviously is the organization everyone
is now working remotely and you know
people are dealing with their own you
know some people have young ki i have
young kids at home but i have a lot of
support at home as well but you could
imagine a lot of folks have young kids
and so that we're trying to work with
all of our team members to make sure
that they're they feel fully supported
as they have all of these competing
tensions and just as an organization and
we're trying to accelerate forward as
many things as we can do but as i said
in earlier you know where we most of our
resources come from philanthropy and you
know so that's a lot of that's that's
very front of mine these days is making
sure we can raise enough money to do the
things we're already doing especially to
the earlier question you know we're
going into harder economic times who
knows what happens to donations over the
next couple of months so I'm definitely
that's some little thing that that I
sometimes wake up and think about and
you know and and how could we
potentially get more resources so that
we can accelerate even more add more
subject areas improve our platform etc
so that's kind of the stuff that at the
Khan Academy level we've been thinking
about
so Bobby Lin Joseph karat from Facebook
on this very nice sound a question it
sounds like they they've a teacher so
you know I know a week past teacher
appreciation week but thanks Bobby
Lynn Joseph karat for being a teacher
and it sounds like you know you're
you're really into Khan Academy thank
you for that so let's see there is so
many good questions you this is an
explorer question or you're asking
really interesting questions Sal where
in the u.s. would be a good place to
live for a lifelong learner you know
I've actually had this I've gone through
this thought experiment before in my
life because as you can imagine Silicon
Valley is not a cheap place to live and
when Khan Academy was just me and a
walk-in closet and we were living off
the savings I used to you know look at
other places in the country that had a
nice climate that had a better cost of
living and thought about whether I
should move there not with the family so
you know there's there's some there's
some nice places in well there's nice
places everywhere but I I definitely you
know San Diego is now quite expensive
too but it is cheaper than the Bay Area
but the Bay Area is actually a great
place for a lifelong learner I mean the
cost of living is very high but as I say
you know your backyard because the
weather is good you can you can view
that as one of the rooms of your house
so that that makes it a little bit
better yeah whether there's a lot of
places I you know depends what you look
for for me it's really who you surround
yourself with you know do you have a
good friend friendships community are
there other people who intellectually
stimulate you around if you have that
you know almost anywhere can be
can be pretty incredible so let's see I
guess let's see are there any other
questions well there's so many I feel
like going through all of this but I I
know I'm guessing I'm missing a meeting
right now I've been guilty of that
before this he's Sammy Sultana what
inspired to study at MIT well I don't
wanna make this a big MIT Anna I think
there's many unit great universities but
it was I'll tell you the story when I
was seven years old my my mother's
second two youngest Branka brother so my
uncle at the time who we were we weren't
living we were living with them in a
while but but anyway we were at his
house I remembered this house seven
years old and he was in college at the
University of New Orleans and he and I
remember him doing some math and I
remember being intrigued because it
looked just like random symbols to me I
was like his name is Dale Shaab mamamoo
mamamoo in and our language means uncle
mother's brother so i said they'll shout
mom will what is this and he said Sal
this is calculus and I was like what is
calculus and he's like well it's this
math where he tried to explain and then
I said can you teach me calculus and
then and he's like well no I don't know
if I can teach you calculus and I was
like why do you need to learn calculus
and he's like well I'm studying to be an
engineer and I said and I remember this
super vividly and I said well what does
an engineer do and he's like well an
engineer builds things to you know solve
problems in the world like he wanted to
become a mechanical engineer and then I
said well then I want to be an engineer
too and then he said well if you want to
be an engineer you should go to MIT and
he doesn't remember I've told them this
I've told him this story many times he
has no recollection of the story but I
had no idea what MIT was what it stood
for where it was but something just
entered into my brain based on what my
uncle's you know five-minute
conversation with me when I was seven
it's like oh I should go there and and
you know I remember what when I went to
high in high school in ninth or tenth
grade it just kind of stayed in the back
of my mind and then when I talked to the
guidance counselor about it the guidance
counselor's like Sal you got to up your
game a little bit not that not that I
was a you know not a good student but
you know our
I grew up in Louisiana and there's
probably about five kids a year who go
and and I didn't go to one of the famous
schools in the state and so anyway
that's I was always enamored by the
notion and you know for me personally it
was wonderful place
you know I there's a lot of it's a place
you know I I gave a commencement address
at MIT a couple years ago and I said
it's the closest thing I can think of on
the planet to like Hogwarts where you
know you can debate whether there's real
magic in the world but a place where
people are focused on creating cool
things that could help humanity and are
creative about it and are very very
accepting of people's eccentricities I
thought was was really nice and I've
obviously made some of my best friends
from from college and I met my wife
there so I definitely I had a good
experience but obviously I think any
experience you know one thing I've
learned in life is it's not where you go
it's not it's not all of these things we
often put a lot of importance on it's
the energy that you project outward so
if you go wherever you go to college if
you say hey this I am so lucky I get to
be in an environment that is focused on
learning an environment where I can meet
friends and bond and be open if you put
that energy out there the friendships
will happen you will learn you will
explore people will gravitate to you but
if you go with kind of a cynical
attitude and you're like oh these people
are out to compete with me or you know
this isn't my first choice school or
things like that
then it'll kind of be a self-fulfilling
prophecy so I would say regardless of
where you want to go obviously I only
had one college experience and that was
MIT and I and I really enjoyed it but
what I found
whether it's at MIT or other places
there were people who didn't have a good
experience and oftentimes it might have
been because it came with some cynicism
tore in or whatever and so that that's
my best advice it's not you know going
this school or that it's it's the
attitude that you bring to it so we're
all out of time I mean you know I'm
enjoying hamming it up with y'all right
now and y'all are asking some really
good questions but we'll have more of
these ask Sal anything sessions in the
future so thanks a bunch for for joining
and everyone have a wonderful weekend
thanks for joining the live stream I'll
see you all on Monday
you